can I tell your Amsterdam story yeah of
course so we we went out there we did
the red light district we dabbled right
he gets I didn't dabble we all right
I'll did
it I dable [__] the red lights were
green that night it's a go D though he
gets duped on one he gets duped finessed
he comes back to the bar never DED on a
hooker or what should we uh it was you I
I need a little more context what was he
trying he got that pyramid scheme hooks
she came in with 200 and was like no no
go go she came in was like it's $200 and
then he goes okay and then he goes all
right what about this he goes okay it's
300 and then another just give me
details dude let's not these These are
hor so I'll do this and you and you jump
in with the this is a hooker that Trevor
is being a hooker to be clear say again
this what you're talking about sex
workers right yeah yeah we went to am CA
employee but you did drugs out there so
he's still trying to figure out wait on
the I I just did it how did the air get
it's okay it's all right you okay no I
cuz they did drugs out there too a lot
and they put that on the pods I want to
distinguish everybody saw that clip cuz
sometimes we watch our friends clips and
sometimes we
don't okay okay okay so this is not
about you guys buying shrooms and doing
them on the Pod this is about sex
workers this is about sex workers so
obviously Amsterdam has a red light
district we had to we had to dabble so
we went uh I found literally one of the
hottest one I ever SE cuz when I went I
was like they're going to be average
they're not hot okay tense like tense
body they look like they're airbrushed
and they're not they're so [__]
unbelievably hot so I I was going to say
found one whatever I found one open up
and I was like I found one and I was
like uh how much she goes $100 and I was
like the [__] I'll give you gu he'll
spend money on oh yeah so I get in there
blah blah blah uh swipe my card and then
we get on the bed and then she puts a
condom on and then puts uh like a paper
towel with a hole in it a big hole
around my dick
she took a big pen it was a big one and
then she put uh put it over right and
then literally bro so I'm sitting on the
thing the most apathetic hand job ever
right so she goes she's leaning forward
and just goes like
this off no eye contact nothing right so
I don't know if you guys know this I
can't get hard at all right so then she
looks at me she goes uh do you want me
to give you head and I was like oh yeah
yeah yeah then she goes $100 and I go I
already it's like Spirit Airlines you
know we're adding on we're adding on you
got you pay for the seat now let me beat
that meat 100 bucks so okay so $5,000
later so so we're so we're at 200 right
and in my head ago I literally thought
of you hey yo dick hard not hard
actually I thought of you and I was like
we're at Amsterdam let me experience
this what am I going to be a [__] Jew
here who cares swipe it he is a Jew for
the I am a Jew blin K so I um he got his
K Card
chill we in
here so um so I'm like I'm like [__] it
let's let's experience this right um and
then so whatever it was a thing and then
and I still can't get hard right and
then she's like do want to [__] and then
I
go okay cut to the chase [__] like
let's do this what's the bottom line
another another 200 I think um and then
and then I and I I still can't get hard
because she's not doing anything to a
rout there's no connection obviously
there's no chemistry obviously right she
looks hot but that's it what are your
goals and aspirations yeah I mean l like
literally let me read your diary
something so so I can't get hard right
and then she just stands up she goes
well I mean you can't get hard so oh wow
it's over [__] she go times up she go
times up she goes you get 20 minutes in
here she goes it's 19 minutes um you got
one minute left there's nothing we can
really do in a minute right yo she gave
you a 19 15 minute salt
job that's great ASMR [__] you know dude
I think you're forgetting intermittently
of intermittently of that 19 minutes
we're doing money transactions and
haggling what is so an apathetic hand
job and haggling she's asking for the
cbv you know yeah I mean I'm literally
my dick is inside of me right it's the
most the most unattractive like
situation I've ever been in also again
I'm stingy so I'm doing this math in my
[__] head I can't get hard what I'm
doing this attacks right off I'm I'm
texting my wealth manager yeah yeah um
anyway she goes yeah and I go I go it
hasn't been 19 minutes she goes it has
and I go no it hasn't do you know why
cuz I tell time for a
living I tell time for a living that's
what I said you're
delusional because because of standup
you generally always know about what 20
minutes is what 45 is what an hour is
but an insane thing this girl doesn't
speak English it's like I tell I can
feel time I can feel time 16 minutes how
long been doing this uh we have been
recording 1445 not bad not bad that's
not bad not bad would be hard if we were
jerking you off right now not bad and
and the same time we I told the story
too I looked at Gabe who was who's our
producer on sift Soxs and I said the
time and it was like 47 minutes I 47
minutes he was like bro it's like it was
like 465 or some [__] so anyways so I
give your time [__] wasn't I wish it
wasn't
but it wasn't 19 minutes it it was been
seven or8 minutes so I just start fuming
I'm like $500 at the bar together we got
our two producers at the bar waiting cuz
they're loyal men [__] are loyal men
I mine was the easiest $200 Hey Bada
Bing Bada Boop we're nothing right and
then I'm at the bar waiting for him this
guy comes in
fing You Know M when he's mad I've never
seen him this mad I've never seen him
this mad he had the spirit he about to
fly home he he was I told him I was like
yo if if there was a ticket presented to
me I would have flown home cuz the thing
loves more than anything is sex and the
thing he hates more than anything is
spending money so he just spent a lot of
money the thing he hates to not do the
thing he loves yeah and I got Bamboozled
the Bamboozled thing is the thing that
[__] kills me Hoodwink by a hoe God damn
I was so mad so I talk him out it's like
we got to get you back out there man you
can't this can't be your one amam
experience we leave in like a day let's
let's get you back out you know because
I it was so fun it was great so I go we
got to get you that too right this is
where we all come back full circle to
what you were talking about he goes
finds a nice lady they get an attraction
they're talking oh zodiac signs
Capricorn they hit it off and they do
that but then he tells me the next
morning after he did the fornication he
went home and still beat his meat yeah
yeah had to get it out yeah I'm sorry no
response on that he 39 was crazy beat
the me but like think about that got
blue ball finally got one off and then
goes back home and goes if anybody's
[__] jerking me it's me I think I
think that's kind of what it is because
[__] is fun but like I know how to
pledge myself the best oh you got a
problem yeah he's a sex
addict but I'm a controlled sex addict
do you know what I mean like here's no
this is I'm saying when blow's in a
relationship he is faithful he's like
working on communication all the gate
things I work on all the time BL does
that in a
relationship are
destroyed I'm sure yeah
in there and [__] you know beating off
is that's still very faithful when
you're in a relationship that's what
he's doing but a [__] switch flips on
and off in single and in a relationship
I've never seen anything like it quick
question with the first chick is it like
when you go to a bar and she's like you
want to keep the tab open like how is
she upping up the transaction does she
stop jerking your [__] off and an
account in the corner just I'll tell you
what it is it's it's the game I think
I'm pretty sure they all play where it's
like once I get a man hard he will do do
anything so once once you weren even
hard I wasn't but like in my you were
mentally hard yeah so so that's what it
was like she gets you hard and then she
goes oh do you want this and you go yeah
so when you say yeah does she take out
the machine and be like all right Apple
pay it and then oh shitzy so she like a
lot of cars are like going through and
shit's not working out you know and also
youle it was crazy it's the cuz yeah cuz
to tr Point like if you spend $200 at a
[__] at a spa in Amsterdam whatever
the [__] it's it's going through the
credit card machine it it the chase is
not going to allow you to do another 100
[__] 10 minutes later get so it's
fraud so I'm I'm answering text message
from Chase yeah it's all good I'm trying
to get blown it's like dude everything
is the most unot yelling in the corner
customer service customer service I'm
about to nut yo why don't you just go
with like a high class spend a little
money it's done dude it's business what
do you mean like I'm sure there's high
class hookers in Amer is like it's
$1,000 for the night and then you just
have we didn't know and I'm telling you
I know what you're picturing like they
like can I be honest I've been to the
red light district and it [__] sked
me out dude yeah it's not disgusting it
was disgusting thing it's like and then
the guys have the creepiest [__]
looks when they're going in it's just
like oh god dude this is all gross dude
the the funniest thing ever is when fine
but like just pay and have it in a
private thing when I came out of the
second one I was all nutted I got nut
out and the woman was nice and then the
moment the moment I come out there's a
[__] fan from the podcast be like BL
this the moment and you feel horrible
dude like you don't feel great coming
out of there you know what I mean not
anyway it's straight into the mix there
just hundreds of people it's like a
parade of horniness and you're like how
do I is there a back entrance and you're
like YouTube Superstar I hat hood on I'm
I'm I'm looking low I was on my phone be
like where's the tax yeah is this for
lift and then I just sck
on you got a phone charger all right
here's cash app the funny thing is like
am we were uh he was getting recognized
obviously more than me but like we were
all getting recognized and then we went
to AA or Bea whatever the [__] and we're
like all right hell yeah this is like ho
Central yeah zero people give [__] knew
who we were zero like I'm talking about
n like they wouldn't even look at us it
was such a [__] disparity between two
places they didn't give a [__] was
hilarious we we got a boat he he was so
nice he rented the the the company a
boat that's great no ho one guy the
whole timer there three days goes yo
YouTube short
oh [__]
right Dam you got a yach with
no here y with no hoses a crazy we we
had a yacht no hose and there was a boat
there's this big ass boat what it was
wasn't even a nice boat chalk full of
Hose the most ho I've ever seen on one
[__] boat in my life zero want to get
on a boat no one wanted to get on a boat
oh my God zero they look like the
picture of the Giants where they had
Tims and [__] like
that it's like yo we fly on his boat
with no what's funny is we were
justifying like you know man it's just
that's what we need just a trip for the
boys nobody is more like reflective on
their own life with a guy with no ho
like man wish we needed just the boys
out you know we didn't even want they're
just going to get in the way do what
they're going to give us head who cares
we don't need that we just need ho we
just need us and cheesecakes but yeah
jerked off after red light disc that's
crazy jerk off again had sex four times
of the girl within 12 hours or whatever
and then later that night he was like I
need a fifth do you think five nuts in a
in a calendar day is crazy guys tour
dates I'm going to be in Atlanta October
27th through 29th hurry up and buy your
tickets because they're going fast
December 1st and 2nd I'm going to be in
Portland begrudgingly against my will I
hate that City but I have a feeling they
have great comedy fans because you're
probably tired of live in there with
them antifa idiots so tickets available
on my website for that also December 8th
New Orleans is one of my favorite cities
I've ever been to I'm excited to go back
and perform comedy and UK I got to
announce these dates because tickets are
almost sold out Glasgow December 17th
London December 18th and Manchester
December 19th also last announcement I
promise January 18th through 20th DC
Improv hurry up and buy your tickets for
those shows and more at Akash singh.com
now let's get back to the show Z beo
still that high it's pretty hot it just
it depends on like it's very
situational like if I'm in a
relationship
nah I mean do you guys know me we no we
don't we have no idea what you mean we
[__] all the time right a I know i'
be harassing the [__]
out I love it dude I love it you a half
at least huh she getes me one and a half
at least all right you know I mean one
and a half week I appreciate you have
you ever seen those sitcoms in like the
90s or whatever married children where
just never wants to have sex with his
wife uh well well actually I'm I'm
thinking like the inverse actually when
the dude's always trying and the woman's
like he won't leave me alone blah
I think I think it's always so funny
well I mean you're going really against
this point of M but like but like the
the that's never the like the girl's
like okay you want it it's like dude
it's the you have do you have the same
you have the same [__] right that I've
been [__] for three years then I'm
good I'm good it sounds mean but like
I'm good that's why you need the new new
that's why I'm a maniac when I'm single
cuz it's all new hey future blow girls
this is what you got to look forward to
also guys I'm not going to wa time
talking sports with these two because
they don't know nothing about it so if
you didn't know I had been on an
unbelievable cold streak on price picks
we're going to keep it going you know
the plan you pick the exact opposite of
what I suggest and that's going to make
you money also you sign up at price.com
and use the promo code Schultz they will
match your initial deposit up to $100 so
if you invest a 100 you deposit 100 you
get 100 for free it's uh you really
can't lose unless you're me and then you
find a way to lose every week but that's
how you win just pick the opposite of me
okay